استهداف روسيا خارج اوكرانيا هي
استراتيجيه بالحرب اعتمدتها كيف على مدى
الاشهر الماضيه اما الهدف الرئيسي
والمتكرر فتمثل بمقاطعه بيلجو دروسيه
الاقرب الى حدودها فباتت الاكثر تضررا
داخل الاراضي الروسيه من هذه الحرب
بالقرود اذا كما نتابع تقع عند هذه النقطه
جنوب غربي روسيا وتبعد نحو 50 كيلومترا عن
حدود اوكرانيا وتتشارك معها حدودا طولها
540 كيلومترا تعد اقرب مدينه روسيه الى
اقليم
بمسافه 71 كيلو مترا فقط اهميه بالقرود
تعود لجغرافيتها فهي تتقاطع كما نتابع مع
انهار كبيره اهمها دونات وسيفرسكي واوسكول
وتميزها خطوط سكك حديديه وطرق سريعه تربط
موسكو بالمناطق الجنوبيه والغربيه لروسيا
وحتى ايضا اوكرانيا ما يعني انها موقع في
استراتيجيات الامداد والتحرك الروسي في
الداخل الاوكراني ففيها طريق شبه جزيره
القرم الخط السريع كما تتابعون خط سكه
الحديد موسكو
هي تشكل محطه لوجسيه روسيه هامه كذلك حيث
يتم تدريب الاحتياط الذي قد يتحرك باتجاه
خركيب او ازيوم كما تتمثل الاهداف
الرئيسيه الاخرى بمخازن الوقود وذخيره
وخزانات ومصافي وخطوط البترول
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات